today's special guests in the faith and
globalization project our two clergymen
from Northern Ireland who played
significant roles in the process that
brought peace to that province after
almost 30 years of sectarian strife they
had the Reverend G Harold good a
Methodist minister who served as the
president of the methodist church in
Ireland in 2001 2002 he also directed
the quarry milla centre for
reconciliation for five years and served
on the Human Rights Commission he
brought his religious commitments to the
service of society in other capacities
as well for instance as a member of the
United Kingdom Social Security Advisory
Committee from 1982 1998 and as chair of
the Northern Ireland Commission for the
care and resettlement of offenders from
1992 to 2001 our other special guest his
father Alec Reid a Catholic priest of
the Redemptorist order from tipperary
who was a deigned in 1957 after pastoral
service in various parts of Ireland he
moved to the cloud monastery in Belfast
where he would spend 40 years on the
fault line between the nationalist
Catholic community and the Protestants
of Shankill Road he became an icon of
the troubles in 1988 when he
administered the last rites to two Royal
Signals corporals killed by the
Provisional IRA in the 1980s and 90s he
facilitated contacts between the various
political factions in Northern Ireland
and between them and the Irish
government in Dublin more recently he's
been involved in peace efforts in the
Basque region of Spain where in 2002 he
won the sabino arana foundation prize in
recognition of his peacemaking efforts
father read and Reverend good worked
together in the after the signing of the
good friday peace accord in 1998 one
important provision of that Accord was
that the IRA decommissioned their arms
in 2005 Reverend good and father read
with the authorities who certified that
the IRA had complied with that provision
of the peace
agreement we're delighted to have you
both here today thank you I'd like to
begin by exploring with father read and
Reverend good and the role that faith
played in the Northern Ireland peace
process but let me begin with a
background question and I'll direct this
to Reverend good what role to the clash
of Protestant and Catholic faiths play
in the perpetuation of the troubles in
Northern Ireland this is a difficult one
to help people to understand because
around the world or is the impression
that this is Catholics coming out of
their church and Protestants coming out
of theirs and getting embroiled and
violence and battle with one another I
think one knots to understand something
of the history of our island and of our
peoples on the island of Ireland we have
two peoples setter people who were the
scotch and the English and therefore
Protestant and we had the indigenous
native Irish who would have been ruling
Catholic in their tradition faith and so
the conflict has been a clash of
cultural identities within which
religion plays a part but this is much
more to do with culture than Creed much
more to do with territory than theology
that is not to say that as in situations
similar to this around the world
religion does not play a part of course
it does because our religious identities
and our cultural identities they do
intertwined and the overlap so that all
too easily we become chaplains to our
own tribe and therefore we consciously
or unconsciously become part of the
problem and we become over identified
with the aspirations or the identities
which sadly because I think to me this
is a denial of our prophetic rule sadly
we then become unfree and less able to
be the kind of reconcile errs and
healers and builders of bridges
we are called to be in our immediate the
gospel of Christ thank you and that's
helpful to keep in mind they the complex
situation in Ireland between the social
and they religious father read could I
ask you to reflect a little bit on a
process of peacemaking but with some of
the major episodes during the 80s and
90s that led members of the Catholic
community for us to embrace the road to
peace well just before I ask that was
just in relation to this question of
Catholics and Platinum's see for
historical reasons and most of the
unionist community which is the
community that once the north of Ireland
to remain united to the United Kingdom
that's why they call unionists they were
settlers and there were Protestants the
native Irish who want Ireland to be
united and separated from the United
Kingdom they were Roman Catholics so the
clash is really between unionists people
who want Northern Ireland to remain part
to united kingdom and nationalists who
what northern ireland to become part of
united Ireland that's the class but it
just happens that for historical reasons
as i said the the union is nearly all
Protestants and the cat and the
Nationals are nearly all Catholics then
people get it impressionist Catholics
and Protestants nothing to do with
Catholicism and Protestantism is a
purely political clash over whether the
north of Ireland should be part of the
United Kingdom or whether it should have
been part of do you know that is where
it is it just happens that the National
necessary mostly Catholic and the
Unionists are mostly Protestant and he
we get this impression there's Catholics
and balances and not only do with
Catholicism granting that the the major
problem is a political bond religious
leaders played a significant role in
helping to resolve it rod and could you
think with us about that and how on the
catholic side they were efforts in that
direction while you see from the point
of view of the in catholic church its
approach was to try to end the suffering
that the conflict was causing
to stop people being killed or injured
or suffering heartbreak and so the
churches are that was its focus we want
to stop people been killed and injured
therefore its head on our own side the
national side we have the IRA who are
causing death and injury so the primary
objective of the church's approach was
to persuade the IRA to stop their armed
campaign in and that way to stop people
being killed and injured at least as far
as the IRA were concerned so that was
the way we we if you like that's what we
want to apply we wanted to stop the IRA
and in relation to doing that we went to
the leader the political leader of of
the IRA of your like our champagne Gerry
Adams very very gifted politician and he
said if you want to stop the IRA there's
only one way and that is to get a
strategy for settling the conflict in a
democratic way which will represent a
consensus between the three main parties
and nationalist parties namely shin Fane
the SDLP you're a big Nationalist Party
peaceful party and the Irish government
for this we said there's only one way if
you have a strategy to settle the
conflict that is a consensus strategy
between the three main nationalist
parties the IRA will stop for that so
then we had to set up a sailboat and
setting up a strategy that was common to
the three parties stlp shin fan in the
irish government and the PM John Hume
the leader of the SDLP he said what
we'll do is we persuade the two
governments the IRA and the Irish
government and the British government to
make a common statement every sabrage
government will recognize the right of
the Irish people to self-determination
and then the understanding was that if
the eye of the british and irish
comments made that statement the area
would stop so that was kind of the way
we went about it and I took us some time
to get the wording of a statement that
the two governments would make and for
which the IRA would stop to his about
nine months but eventually we did and
this John Major was the British prime
minister and bertie ahern was the Irish
Prime Minister and we ended up then with
with a statement to which the Iowa for
to which the IRA agreed that if this
statement was made by the two
governments they would stop but in the
event John Major who is depending on the
unionists in the Westminster Parliament
to stay in power at the time he was a
minority government he had a he had to
change really the wording that we
brought to him and for which the IRA
were going to stop well the result was
when the two governments made the
statement in December 1993's known as
the Downing Street statement the IRA
didn't stop immediately because it
wasn't the wording to which they had
agreed but I know from my contacts that
word in or say that would the statement
was made in December by March at latest
the IRA has decided to stop in response
to that statement could we pause there
and it's interesting how religious
leaders are playing a significant role
in pushing political negotiations along
and facilitating them is that a fair
statement well and I mean as I say our
primary objective was to stop even being
killed and injured from our side of the
conflict and that means stopping the IRA
so our primary focus was how do we stop
the IRA I'd be interested to hear
Reverend good talk a little bit about
attitudes on the the other side the
other side and what the Protestant
leadership was doing yeah I think one
thing that should be said is that they
there are four call of four main
churches in Ireland they would be the
rumor Catholic they Anglican you call
Piscopo Presbyterian and Methodist and
the leadership of those four churches
have come together and work quite
closely
other will do many things together and
think this is very important that
they're seen to be together in the
divided society that there are these
visible symbolic expressions of being
United and what really matters and I
think the church has two rules to play
we are not politicians we're not a
political party we're not even an
alternative to a political party we have
two rules one is pastoral and one is
prophetic and father Alec has spoken
about the pastoral side we all shared
that deep concern to stop the killing to
try and put grief to be a thing of the
past so much pain and heartache on both
sides all sides that is a pastoral
concern and to bind up the wounds of the
brokenhearted that was a very important
part of our rule and if you do not help
people to deal with their grief and or
hurt than their pain and their anger
then it's going to come out and be
expressed and yet more violence and so
that was a very important rule for all
of us the pastoral rule but it was also
the prophetic rule and that is to
challenge the institutions of state is
the challenge the political parties it
is to be constantly and aggressively
questioning it is to be aggressive in
the face of injustice and I think which
marginalizes people are reduces the
dignity of a human person all of those
and at the end of the day what we should
have been asking and I don't think we
did this as well as we should but we're
learning and the question the churches
should have been asking must now ask is
not whether or not we should be a united
kingdom or a united Ireland I don't
think that that is the primary question
for us within the leadership of the
churches the question is what kind of
society do we want what are the values
upon which we base our society whether
it be at a United
this re-united that or whatever what
signed society what are the values that
reflect not the kingdoms of this earth
but the kingdom of God on earth and that
I think is a very fundamental rule for
us in the churches mm-hmm they never
tried to see what you have to do with
people who are involved in if you like
armed struggle as they would say is to
engage them you have to talk to them
meet them and if you do you together
you'll get you do business with them and
they'll do business with you but
standing at a distance and shouting at
them is not the way it's not a way to
deal with with armed people I think just
all that institutions but their very
nature are unwieldly things it's
difficult to get an institution it's
like trying to move an army you know and
there are times when the best business
is done by the foot soldiers by
individuals rather than the institutions
and I think that's alright as long as
those individuals have the support and
the blessing of the institution to act
in their name and I think that some of
the most important work in peacemaking
in our context has been people like I'll
agreed and others of us who have behind
the scenes not making headlines at the
time just working quietly creating space
for people to meet people who otherwise
would not have met to create opportunity
for people from different sides to
engage an honest dialogue where they
could be open with each other and I
think it was a very important role for
individuals from within the communities
of faith on both sides institutions find
it difficult to do that because they
have to bring their constituencies with
them but we could go into the quiet
places a bit like people who set the
stage when the curtain is pulled you
know who cares who adjust to the lights
and
move the furniture what it matters and
that was a very important rule for some
of us who felt under the compulsion of
the gospel to create that kind of
objective space say a little bit more
about that process of building bridges
and creating spaces for inter-communal
and interfaith dialogue what kinds of
strategies did you did you adopt to make
that happen father read well I'll tell
you our approach to the conflict as they
say was to stop the IRA now the IRA were
fighting what they were called the
British presence you know they said it
but Britain united kingdom had no right
to be in Ireland and under soldiers no
right to be walking our streets so their
whole objective was to put their input
the Brits out as they would say putting
yourself this way there was the company
IRAs campaign and and we as I say it
tried to press which we we did persuade
him to take a peaceful that I approach
to put him to vote because they all do
nationalist parties agree that they
should get out you know answer the
question of persuading area to take a
peaceful approach now as far as the
unionist people were concerned we had we
didn't worry too much about the
unionists and because our warrior was to
stop the IRA killing people you know and
that had to do with
the British and the Irish themselves
coming together to get a peaceful way of
putting the mouse and as I say we walk
very little very very little in terms of
trying to bring about reconciliation
between the two communities because our
big job was to stop the IRA as I say and
then you see what happened then was when
the IRA is stopped and the loyalists
stopped they issued a statement very
quickly saying we were stopping do you
know so that the violence from both
sides stopped when the IRA stopped a
loyalist out and that was a big I mean
it was absolutely fundamental to the
peace process that the IRAs stopped I
never pre appreciated how much a
ceasefire would mean but once the IRAs
stopped then the whole situation opened
up people could start meeting and
negotiating and shin Fame the you know
the Republican Party the IRA party were
like they were invited into normal
political discussion and the whole thing
really started to move and the IRS
stopped because then contacts were open
between including you see how to bring
in the Republicans that was in vain if
you're going to be realistic about
having a real dialogue and then and they
shun famer acceptable to the other
political parties once the IRAs stopped
I don't know if that I think that's very
important so a key for a step in moving
a peace process forward was to get some
internal cohesion and and harmony within
what are the communities rather than
building a bridge to the other and that
was used to say peace in Ireland means
peace among the artists once the Irish
made peace among themselves that was it
war was over that because then you cuz
don't know you know whatever other
problems you could nationals were though
as one body to you to negotiate but the
big thing was to stop the Irish fighting
among themselves and once you did that
and I was at the road was opened down
for whatever to the good fight
agreements and whatever else you wanted
me to go see a human what was some of
the strongest resistance you had
moving in that direction of peace when I
how do you answer well I think in all
sorts of situations of conflict there's
always resistance on the part of people
to talk with their enemy that's seemed
to be capitulation not seem to be
compromised not seen to be surrender if
you talk to your enemy this isn't just
peculiar to Ireland this is we lift up
to a global debate and I think it's
something that this country is now
beginning to address and think about and
you know from the debate around and
coming up to the election on that issue
and we had to learn that whatever our
people were frightened the idea I mean I
as a Protestant minister there are
people in my community particularly
those who had suffered lost loved ones
who when they knew that some of us were
talking with the perceived enemy felt we
are about to surrender something and yet
wasn't robein the Prime Minister of
Israel who said when he did exactly this
when he was photographed shaking hands
with Yasser Arafat and the whole roof
fell in on him and he said you don't
make peace by talking with your friends
you must talk with your enemy and that
was I think a rule for some of us within
the communities of faith the religious
life of the community to say the one we
serve told us what we had to have a
different attitude towards our perceived
enemies then the old way and that was a
very important breakthrough to for
people to talk and then to lift that
from behind the scenes as it were-- to a
more public profile where governments
had to talk with each other and to talk
with the leadership of the paramilitary
organisation
and the IRA and begin to engage and that
brought us all four because our history
has been based on exclusion excluding
people and that is a recipe for nothing
but grief to exclude people and so we
had to find ways of bringing each other
in bringing each other in not bringing
you in and bringing you but bringing
each other in and that was a big
breakthrough and that led to the Good
Friday Agreement which was a remarkable
breakthrough chaired by Senator George
bit chilly did a wonderful job in our
community and because we had to move
beyond exclusion could I ask you both in
conclusion to reflect just a little bit
on the the resources you brought to the
task to get to get people to think about
embrace rather than exclusion father
e-resources mm-hmm spiritual resource
virtual resources we have I call the
golden rule of peacemaking is that you
do what you reasonably can and then you
leave it to the Lord and you do it
you're reasonably can you don't have to
lose any sleep over it or straighten put
a strain in your health you do what
you're reasonably can to sort out the
problem do you leave it to the Lord and
I that the Lord and comes along behind
and he starts out the bits and pieces
that you weren't able to sort out but
you do what you reasonably can and as
long as you're doing what you reasonably
can you can be certain that the Lord
will back you up them sort off and needs
to be sorted out so that was if you like
if you didn't worry we weren't anxious
as you knew that if you did which a
reasonably cold you could rely on the
Lord to bring the thing in the ring the
team to a good contribution under then
did that work that's the experience we
have so if you like that's where your
faith if you like gave your courage and
gave you a peace of mind if you like you
know what you know we were doing with
your reason we can burn wood weren't
lying awake at night right we're doing
which a reasonably coat then we were
certain the Lord will back you up and
bring the whole thing to a good
contribution and that's that's the way
it works so this way your faith if you
like gave you the car
engine gave you the kind of sense that
you didn't have to worry just do what
you can reasonably can so that's where
your faith you know no great source of
strength of you know related to that or
to spiritual factors that come to my
mind resources but one is hope the whole
biblical narrative is one of hope
looking forward and then the face of
those who say it can never be any way
different from this you know a law would
be like this you know we had to keep we
had to nurture hope and I remember going
to our world council of churches
conference in Bangkok away back in 1973
i think it was and the most of it went
over my head but there was one phrase
that I brought home with me which was
well worth going to Bangkok to hear and
it was the theologian Jurgen maltman in
his presentation who said always
remember that Christ takes the
inevitability out of history and I hung
on to that phrase throughout all those
dark ears from people said there's no
solution that'll never be any different
I always remembered Christ takes the
inevitability out of history that's hope
and the second thing is and I said as
Anna somebody coming from the
evangelical tradition they possibility
for change in the human heart and mind
that we are all capable of being
transformed and changed and when we see
people who we feel are diametrically
opposed to the peace that we want we
have to remember they too or children of
this God who has redeemed us all through
Christ and there is for all of us this
opportunity for change and we're seeing
it we are actually seeing if we are
seeing people who said no and
ever who are now working together in
partnership and the change of heart
change of heart that's the key to all of
our conflicts in the world change of
mind is important but change of heart is
fundamental well thank you both and I
think we can conclude on that very
hopeful note the emphasis on the
importance of faith and leaving some
things in the hand of the Lord as an
inspiration to continue to work and the
notion that hope is going to be a
guiding principle of engaging in very
difficult situations and I congratulate
both of you on the marvelous work you've
done for peace in Northern Ireland and
thank you for being with us for this
this time today thank you very much
thank you very okay god bless you